[Music]
let's go to k in des moines
in des moines what's up k
hey how are you i'm good how are you
good
so what's up how can i help
um we uh lost our
six-year-old son a couple years ago oh
good grief what happened
um he went
swimming with some friends oh man and he
uh drowned i'm so sorry what was his
name
kaden kaden oh my gosh
whoo
yeah it was it was rough um his sister
was there with with them it was
my younger two kids that went with
and
the adult that had him
just wasn't watching him she was over
sun tanning and my kid was off
so anyway but my question is like my
oldest will be 18 pretty soon and
he has not
handled the loss that well
he has gone through a roller coaster the
lowest of his life
um
and i just don't know where i just don't
know how i can help him anymore we've
even tried to send him into an inpatient
treatment um he got kicked out of that
we're trying to get him into a place
right now
but they are looking at his past
he is ready as can be he wants to go
but i don't know what else i can do for
him um places won't take him and i don't
even know how i can even
help him as a mom anymore
i'm so sorry what a mess
um let me ask a couple of background
questions how many how many kids do you
have total
um i had three
three so you had an 18 year old
i held your your daughter
uh she's 14. okay and then kayden would
have been eight yeah okay and would was
that is that three
yep yep and my oldest who doesn't turn
18 until june okay um and so that's why
we're coming into some issues as well so
what's been going on is he using is he
if he's getting kicked out of treatment
centers that means he's got violent
tendency like what's been going on
um
it started with drinking he was drinking
a lot at first when the accident
happened
um like daily
and then he kind of had a scare and then
he led into what was the scary
he
got really really wasted and
he um
passed out like i found him in his truck
uh like 1 30 in the morning um he had no
kind of no idea where i was who i was or
what was going on and it just kind of
scared him till he drove
yeah like 20 to 30 miles from where he
was supposed to been staying at and so
that kind of scared him well then it led
into
um
he led into marijuana um
and so then
he was trying to do that to cover up his
pain um before all of this he
he was a very good a b student
did all sports had a great group of
friends um after the accident he lost
all of that he had no motivation he
didn't do sport his grades
got a different crowd of kids
how did your home
how did your home grieve
is dad at home
yeah yeah okay so how did
dad grieve how did you grieve
um to be honest i don't think we had
have had a chance to okay
um
we kept pushing and pushing to be
to be active to be busy at all times
because we had two kids that were
grieving
and we wanted to make sure that they
were okay um
and so i honestly i don't think we even
have had the chance because
since the accident
we both
have been dealing with now our oldest
and then also trying to make life
okay for our daughter that has seen all
of this and was there for you know
so
i'm going to talk to you because our
time is compressed i'm going to talk
real directly okay
i need you to hear me say you and i are
on the same side of the booth on this
conversation okay
you promise that i can hear in your
voice how close caiden is still sitting
he's still on your chest
oh yeah okay
kayden's still in your home he's still
in your bed
right
mm-hmm okay so i'm gonna speak as though
you and i have talked for a couple of
weeks okay
um and i need you to promise me
something say i promise
i promise
that what i'm about to say is not going
to be guilt-inducing because that's
where you're going to go with it okay
okay
this is about tools and what i mean by
tools is
i had a friend over this weekend helping
me use a chainsaw on to cut down a tree
and
i was trying to do something with an axe
and he pulled out like a hammer and i
felt like an idiot cause i was using the
wrong tool okay
and so all we're talking about is tools
here
you promise you trust me
yep okay
um
first and foremost you've got a teenage
son who you love and it feels like
you're losing another kid
i want you to own that level of gravity
okay
is that does that sound close to home
oh yeah we've actually mentioned that it
feels like we lost him okay feels like
you're losing your your second son okay
in some ways you are but in many ways
you aren't i also want to take drugs and
alcohol huge deal terrifying deal all
that's scary
and here's why i'm not super concerned
about that right this second because
drugs and alcohol work those are the
solutions to his challenges those aren't
the problem right now okay you're gonna
have to deal with the alcohol addiction
and those things when you when but
that's for the professionals and y'all
will get there
often
often parents when they lose a child
they double down and say we've got to
help our other kids and what we want to
do is make things as quote unquote
normal as possible
we don't want them to lose their
childhood because of this we don't want
them to miss out on these experiences
and so a very common narrative usually
at barbells it's one or the other it's
usually
either people shut down and just are
encased in amber like just stuck in
syrup or
everybody says we're going to keep going
going going we will grieve when the kids
go to college we'll do that later
and what can happen not always but what
can happen
is i'm just gonna use your oldest son
i'm gonna name him tom okay
okay
tom looks around his environment
and he does not see anybody exhibiting
what is going on in his body which is
darkness which is a hole which is
a the vacuum that you feel when somebody
so close to you goes away
throw in sister was there and the you
should have been there well i didn't
know that kind of stuff throw in an
adult was there an adult's job is to
keep make sure everybody's okay right so
you throw all that complexity in there
and you've got a 16 year 17 year old
screaming from the inside out
and the greatness sounds sound
counterintuitive the single greatest
gift you can give that 16 year old is
not normalcy because nothing is normal
anymore
what you can give that kid
is
weeping from the bottom of your gut
and holding him
letting him see you and your husband
weep
and say we're not going out this week
we're all just staying in
because what it does for the 16 year old
is it gives him permission to go oh my
god my feelings are normal
i'm not crazy
and what happens over the course of a
couple of years when somebody's deep in
grief
and everyone around them looks like
they're just going on about their day or
trying to have some sense of normalcy
you the pain becomes overwhelming
because now you're isolated now you're
alone
and so this isn't an advice situation
this isn't a
here's the things i didn't tell you
this is about we're going to start
saying caden's name in our home a lot
this is about we are going to all as a
family write letters to caden
tell them how much we miss them
and mom and dad are going to read their
letters to
to brother and sister
and we might not be able to get through
the first one or the second one or the
third one and we might write him a
letter that says i'm so can't believe i
let you go with such-and-such adult
and i you are still wearing a lot of
grief and and uh and guilt too i can
feel it on you okay
but these family discussions these this
this breathability lets caden make his
way through the hearts and minds and
synapses and blood and air of everyone
in that home and right now he's trapped
you hear what i'm saying
and what i'm saying sounds real real
woo-woo and you've probably had to build
some really strong scaffolding to
get through the last few years
if i'm you in your situation where i
would start
is a with my son
with my oldest son
and say
we're going to start with a letter to
caden you and me and i might even go as
far as to say is um
hey we i've tried to do my best and we
missed this one and i'm gonna i'm gonna
start now by um we're gonna grieve this
thing and we're gonna do it together
and i would let your son breathe
and he might have does he is he is he an
alcohol addiction he has a drug
addiction
um
[Music]
yes and no i guess okay it's not as bad
anymore because he's been in the
treatment okay um and so he hasn't been
like really bad it's more of
the mental issues that he has like if
something triggers him yeah
then he might go in the house okay some
drinks or something like that but it's
mainly his mental and he knows he can be
clean it's just
sure so it's it's this it's that it's
that black hole vacuum
of loss
and it's the isolation it's the nobody
else in this house seems to be feeling
this
some kids will go get straight a's with
that feeling some kids will
turn to alcohol and weed because it just
me into pills because it just makes
things
a little less sharp
but i think you're home
starting with you and husbands
and this is hard because
here's what i know about you okay and
i'm not not you about mothers in this
situation
there's this sense that if i start
crying i will never be able to stop
if i drop my shoulders i'm out i'm done
and i'll tell you two things number one
you're right you will cry for caden for
the rest of your life
and
you will find strength and resilience in
your community and in people around you
and in yourself that you did not know
existed
you've got to walk towards caden you've
got to walk towards your oldest son
you've got to walk towards your husband
and your husband's got to walk in the
middle of all this too
so what your family i believe needs
deeply is a
no more running
this is who we are this is where we are
we've experienced this great trauma this
great tragedy we're gonna talk to caden
and at some point
it's gonna be a while
at some point okay you and your husband
y'all are gonna let kaden go
you let him go home
and right now you're hanging on to him
real real real real tight
i'm so so sorry
as it goes for your son
hang in there with the treatment
let him be a part of this grieving
process
if he's struggling with deep mental
health issues talk to that talk to his
counselor about this stuff okay
um don't give him things don't let him
be in situations you can't handle but
tell the tell his counselor
the family's ready to start grieving
this and we have in a long time
and we're going to start today